what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
alright
so technically speaking I'm recording
this one second right like I recorded
Superman peace on earth first because I
never read any of these to the world's
greatest superheroes line of stories I
just googled like Alex Ross art and I
was like where is that story like what
what stories I'm from and then I started
poking around I found world's greatest
superhero and so these are going to be
some stories I'm just going to pepper in
wherever I have a place to put them in I
mean they're not there's not going to be
like a day dedicated to let's just
upload them one week and then you may
not see another one for two or three
weeks I'm just going to kind of cover
them in where I had the ability to do
that because I have a few spots that are
open here and they're over the course of
my schedule or I can just kind of throw
them in there but the idea is that to me
and again I've said this in the Superman
video and I'm going to say it again
because I think it bears repeating Alex
Ross art is some of the best art there
ever was in comic books and there's no
arguing that point I mean it's insane
how good this is because of the emotion
it invokes right like it I look at Alex
Ross's art of superheroes like I look at
the superheroes that he draws the
Avengers the Justice Society of America
especially the Justice Society of
America I look at the pictures that he
draws and it makes me nostalgic for an
era of comics when I wasn't part of like
it kind of makes me look at the heroes
and it's like see those are superheroes
like those are superheroes who don't
have moral ambiguity they know what the
right thing is and they do what the
right thing they do the right thing is
every single time there's no gray area
there there's right and there's wrong
and that's it and that's what I love
about this because it just kind of
captures that era of comic books so I
always imagine that if mom or I'm sorry
of DC we're going to launch um you know
like earth to if they were going to
relaunch earth - I'd want to see Alex
Ross just draw the whole thing the
problem is it would take forever to do
because it takes so long to crank these
out but the cool thing about Batman war
on crime is much like Superman peace on
earth like much like we'll see with that
it strips away all the gadgets and stuff
right because right now if you go out
and you pick up a Batman comic from DC
rebirth and you start going through the
stories that man has gadgets for
everything I mean he's got gadgets he's
got stuff for everything that's his
utility bill the infinite depths of the
utility belt if Batman needs it it's in
the utility bill it's like he found a
genie one day is the genie I wish for a
utility belt that I could reach into and
have whatever
I need for any particular situation
Batman's wish that's his utility belt
but it is kind of cool in the sense that
you know it creates some interesting
stories to create some interesting
situations but for the most part it kind
of takes away from the character right
like Batman doesn't struggle like Batman
always had a solution for everything
Superman comes racing in he's possessed
by Harley Quinn like he wasn't harsh
he's controlled by her nor plants and he
in suit manatorian Batman attack each
other they fight for a little while and
then Batman's got green kryptonite so
Superman's defeated you know the cool
thing about this story war on crime is
it takes all that away and one of the
things that I hope you noticed over the
course of this video as you are not
going to see the Batmobile
once you won't see it one time it does
not exist in here the batwing will not
be seen it'll be nothing but Batman you
know his little gadget some small-time
gadgets here and there and that's it
this story focuses almost entirely on
the character now the cool thing is that
you know Bruce Wayne kind of reflects on
this position as Batman right I mean
says what's you know too much of Gotham
City I'm a ghost
I'm an urban meth I'm a boogeyman I'm a
guy that just goes around and the night
my humble criminals and that's what
Batman relies on that's the core thing
about this Batman relies on fear that
man relies on mystery on intrigue he
relies on the notion that criminals view
him as something almost you know
mythological as something almost
supernatural that Batman's this ghost
this phantom that just haunts around the
city of Gotham and evildoers beware
because Batman will whisk you away to
places unheard of except it's called
Blackgate prison
like it will take you away to bad places
but it's so cool because it's what he
feeds on the fear of villains is what
makes Batman powerful and it's kind of a
funny situation right I mean if no one
was afraid of Batman then Batman
wouldn't be as capable he wouldn't be as
powerful as he is he wouldn't be as
capable of a hero as he is because
there's no fear there there's no reason
to be scared of him if people aren't
scared of him people can focus on them
if people can focus on them they can
find ways to take him out and if they
can find ways to take him out and Batman
will cease to exist
but as long as they're terrified of who
he is they have no reason to try to find
a way to bring him down but the cool
thing is that where he says look my role
as Batman is to patrol around the
streets at night and take people out who
are committing crimes he says I also
have another way in which I fight
villainy I fight villainy in the form of
Bruce Wayne and that's what's so
beautiful about this gives me says not
all crime takes the form of a mugger
with a ski mask holding up a liquor
store some crime takes the form of
refusal to acknowledge other people's
humanity a refusal to acknowledge those
who struggle and those who basically
lose things in the pursuit of trying to
find some measure of happiness in the
life in the life that they lived but
even Bruce Wayne sits down and he says I
can't help but wonder what life would
have been like what would it have been
like if my parents hadn't been killed
what would it have been like if I had
just grown up as an extremely rich guy
what would my life have been like what
is the death of my parents the one thing
is it what is it what allows me to
bridge the gap between the wealthy life
that I live and those who don't have
that kind of luxury was the death of my
parents the way in which that bridge was
built so that I could look upon the city
that I've lived in my entire life and I
can say all those people up there are
being ignored but they're struggling and
someone needs to help them is that what
happened and that's what's so cool about
this because Bruce Wayne sits down right
and there's a guy that basically kind of
rolls into the scene this guy is named
Randall and Randall is a guy that
basically plans on tearing down a
section of Gotham City for the purpose
of just building up this great big huge
monstrosity of what he considers to be a
thriving area now where you basically
says look you know in this Bayside
Bayside industrial complex it's
basically failing like I mean there's
nothing there there's nothing worth
having you know there's nothing worth
worrying about there I mean sure people
are struggling but they're poor who
cares history says it's basically just
kind of run them out and let's do it
this huge I guess condo complex and then
call it a day and it's such a cool thing
because Batman says if these people are
being ignored then why you know and he
says if there's so much crime there
there's so much going on you know then
he says that can't be allowed to happen
I mean there's still good people there
and that's the coolest thing about this
right that's the coolest thing about
Alex Ross's a hold about this whole
store between Paul Dini and Alex Ross we
would look at this and we would say oh
my god here's other political story not
at all this is the two of them sitting
down and saying people are just people
are good sometimes bad things happen to
good people
sometimes good people are thrust into
impossible situations and have to make
bad decisions and yes sometimes there
are just bad people who do bad things
but what this shows us is despite all
the experiences of Bruce Wayne's hat the
death of his parents all his run-ins
with the Joker all the horrible things
he's seen he has not lost his faith in
humanity he has not lost his faith in
who these people are now in this
instance he basically runs into a guy
that is knocking over a local
convenience store
that man chases them down but after
hearing a couple shots of course he goes
inside and what he sees are the store
owners who have basically been killed
well the problem with this is that their
son Marcus is still very much there now
this is this is something this was
beautiful this is something that I
really hope you guys dig there is this
point where Batman looks down at Marcus
and says I see something else something
unexpected but familiar Batman Bruce
Wayne sees himself in this kit there are
totally different circumstances he's
never seen this kid once in his life but
he can see himself in this kid why
because this kid's parents have been
murdered for senseless reason Bruce
Wayne's been down the exact same room
his parents were murdered for simplest
reason for the physical items they
possessed and a guy on hard times
decided that he needed him more than
they did and so Bruce Wayne had to
experience with parents like this kid
Marcus is experiencing the exact same
thing and what this story is designed to
do is take these two concepts and
juxtapose them alongside one another
that this is the road the road that
Marcus is on right now is the road that
Bruce Wayne could have taken and the
whole goal behind this will be to keep
from keep Marcus from falling along this
path from falling down this this you
know negative suit is the circle of
negativity this path of complete and
total destruction something else is
really cool here about what Batman says
is he talks about the scars of loss he
talks about the pain of loss what it
means to lose people who mean something
to you what it means to lose people who
were so close to you and what he says
those scars never go away those scars
stay there sometimes those cars are
physical an abusive parent the scars are
physical from neglect or what have you
sometimes the scars are mental it
reasons your mind
it turns you inside out it turns you
into a self-destructive person sometimes
the scars are just of the soul sometimes
the scars are such a degree that you
just never really recovered but for some
individuals these experiences that they
have will send them into a tailspin
it'll destroy their lives it'll sit them
down spiral and they'll know nothing but
death misery and destruction until the
day they die sometimes they'll die of
natural causes other times they'll die
of artificial causes they'll turn the
gun on themselves somebody will turn the
gun on them or whatever the case may be
what's left of their life will be mired
in tragedy and so what Bruce Wayne does
is he dons a disguise of a homeless man
and that's one of the coolest things
about this if you don't do this guise of
a homeless man it says hey look this is
how I can blend in without anybody
knowing who I am and that's
the things that he does quite frequently
you know matches Malone for example is a
really really good really good identity
that he does but just kind of blend in
with the world just walk around and see
things through the eyes of a normal food
person because you have to keep in mind
you know Bruce Wayne is one of the most
well-known people in the world you know
if you were to start walking around the
streets of Gotham and somebody recognize
them they probably try to rob them now
woe betide the poor soul who makes that
decision but they would probably try to
rob him and so because of that walking
around as a homeless man means that
he'll stay hidden you'll stay ignored
nobody will look in the eye nobody will
look up at him and so while he's making
his way around he kind of stops by that
store that's been shot up you know and
he realizes there's a game it's
effectively tagged it and they're just
kind of spending time there so what he
does if he comes back later on that
night and discovers the suspicions are
true when their intention was to
basically rob the place now this is
something else that I hope you guys
notice here that actually uses a smoke
pellet like he just kind of throws a
smoke bomb in order to keep these guys
keep these guys distracted and that's
the nature of what I love so much about
these Alex Ross Spalding these stories
if it strips away all the super advanced
stuff Batman's not like I run in with a
hologram of myself and then I come in
from behind and take them by surprise
it's nothing you know wildly ridiculous
like that it's simple it's so small and
down-to-earth
it's just Batman you know his little
hook and twine it's Batman smoke bombs
it's just simple homemade basic things I
mean we're the Citizen of the continuity
I don't know and if I don't even think
these have a continuity ending
themselves I think it's just kind of a
series of individual stories that
ultimately culminate in the the
formation of the Justice League but the
idea here is that when Batman makes his
presence known while he's fighting all
these different guys he turns around and
he sees Marcus and that's what's
happening here Marcus is just kind of
falling down this spiral of
self-destruction he's falling down this
path of ending up with all the wrong
people but again switching back over to
Bruce Wayne you know that following day
switching back over to Bruce Wayne when
he's spending time with Randall Winters
again Randall is a guy that wants to
build this great big huge condominium
complex and Bruce Wayne is yet again
pondering what direction his life would
have taken
had he not experienced the death of his
parents and he looks at Randall and he
sees the path that he could have been on
and that something is so ironic here
that's why this story works so well is
because Marcus and Randall are two
distinctly different paths did Batman
that Bruce Wayne's life could have taken
if his parents had lived he could have
gone on to be this really wealthy guy
who cares nothing for the plight of the
common man at the same time with his
parents dying he could have gone on to
become Randall totally self-destructive
leading himself down
the path that could eventually result in
his death if he stays there but the more
that Bruce Wayne looks at Randall
winters the more he says I don't like
this man I don't like this man that's
disconnected from humanity I don't like
this man who would look at the poor and
say your poverty is your problem sorry
about your luck I don't like this man
who would look at individuals and say
this very this part of town maybe it
will be your home
but you're in my way you need to move
you know he's like I do not like who
this man is or what he stands for
now of course Randall is just kind of
injected into the story a little bit and
there'll be more or less uh I guess a
conclusion to his individual character
but at this point we basically pick up
with Bruce Wayne kind of looking at the
stance of saying if Randall Winters is
so held in on Terry down Bayside in
order to basically go through and build
his condominium complex then the only
option that I really have here is to
stand in his way so he says that's what
I'm going to do he's a little we're
going to go through and he's going to
clear out the crime because that's
really what happened here in this
section of Gotham City that once the you
know huge factory had been shut down
what sir they'd gone out of business but
people who lived in this part of town
moved they ran off it was like Detroit
the auto industry failed and everybody
just bailed out in Detroit they took off
to the point that it basically turned
into into a war zone of war zone into
no-man's land no one with any measure of
common sense would go live in Detroit if
they had the choice and so because of
this he said let's solve this problem
let's clear all these criminals out
let's clear our all this crime let's
restore this to a neighborhood that
people want to live in and that's the
essence of the other of the story
Batman's war on crime one of the other
things that he discovers is that where a
lot of the young kids in the
neighborhood are basically getting
involved in what seems to be this you
know this this huge factory the idea is
that they're putting them to work
they're putting the kids to work for the
purpose of gaining money making money on
their own but in a sense these kids are
just being used for a purpose innocence
but this entire place is just making
drugs that's all it is it's a drug
running facility and so as soon as
Batman gets in there he starts going
through all these guys picking them all
out but then he hears a gun behind
him he turns around and Marcus is
standing there and this is the picture
that I put out on Twitter for those of
you guys who follow me on Twitter at
Comics explain this is the picture that
I put out there when he's looking at
Marcus and again he sees himself
I mean Marcus is at a crossroads right
now if Marcus pulls the trigger his life
is over
Batman will survive that's fine Batman
will probably live he has the resources
the means to get around to be sure that
bullet will penetrate
but Marcus doesn't have any measure of
accuracy either he's a kid holding a gun
who's recoil he couldn't even begin to
be able to handle on his own and so the
bullet may fly off to the left or
something like that but I doubt it would
kill drew Swain it might but I doubt it
would kill that man but regardless of
what happens to that man
Marcus's life is done he's a murderer
even if he's not caught by the cops he's
crossed this pack that he can't come
back from he's crossed the line that
he'll never be able to return from and
that's Batman's point Batman says look
we both lost our parents we both
suffered tragedy of an unimaginable
level few people in this world will be
able to experience the tragedy that
we've experienced a lot of people have
lost their parents but not a lot of
people have experienced the loss of
their parents by virtue of being killed
in an alley somewhere because they were
just they had something somebody else
wanted it was a senseless murder and
Bruce Wayne says do not fall down that
road do not let the death of your
parents turn your life inside out do not
let the destruction and the the violence
of other other individuals determine
your life do not become what killed our
families and it is an incredibly
touching moment because this is just
this is Bruce Wayne this was a Batman
talking this isn't Batman talking to
Marcus it's not you know I'm the Dark
Knight and don't let what you know don't
don't be come with your families this is
Bruce Wayne this is the man Bruce Wayne
and that's why it works so well because
it's beautifully done it's just this
chance to save a life and this is what
he talks about this is what Bruce Wayne
says you know while he's observing all
these different things when he begins to
invest in this condominium complex
building this part of town back up he
basically says you know look my goal
here my belief was that if I saved
Marcus I could save myself now of course
with regards to Randall winters all
Bruce Wayne really does is just report
the fact that you know Randall winters
has been backing some criminal action
he's more or less involved with with
crime and the result is that you know
he's reported to Jim Gordon the police
investigate he's most likely going to be
arrested but looking at his overarching
goal so far looking at his overarching
actions that man basically says my goal
is that I you know what's the help
Marcus I believed that if I can help
Marcus I believe that if I could you
know keep Marcus back keep Marcus from
falling down this path of
self-destruction then then maybe I can I
can leave my grief maybe I can walk away
from my grief maybe I can get past my
scars get past my pain he says right now
I'm just kind of waiting for that time
to come and that's what's so sad about
this is there is no there's there's no
one there
that man that man is the savior of
Gotham City who's Batman's Savior who's
coming to rescue Batman who's coming to
rescue him from the pain that he's
experienced who's coming to rescue him
from the trauma that he's endured over
the course of his life there's no one
coming for that he's waiting on his own
Superman his own superhero to come along
and to say everything is okay everything
will be fine I'm sorry this happened but
in the end it's so beautifully done it's
so beautifully read this it's probably
one of the greatest Batman stories there
ever was like it's incredible but if you
guys are new here to come in to explain
make sure you guys as a sub button to
become part of the Robin or if you guys
want to see more videos like this make
sure you drop a like and leave a comment
down below let me know how how do you
think the story compares to the other
Batman stories that you've read before
I'm really really curious to see where
that stamps I imagine some of you guys
might be like man I like the fast pace
you know crazy everything going on
Batman stories and some of you may be
like this is back to you know bachelors
back to its roots Batman this is the
kind of story that I gave so let me know
what side of the fence you guys are on
and yeah I will catch you all later
please
you